Speaker 1: In the immediate aftermath of this
horrible terrorist shooting incident in Buffalo,
New York, over the weekend.
We talked about it Monday.
We talked about it Tuesday.
This was an individual, a white 18 year old,
domestically born American, who was specifically
targeting black people influenced by right
wing ideas regularly parroted out on Fox News,
including of the white replacement theory
or great replacement theory.
White birthrates and other things.
In the immediate aftermath of that, I already
told you that there was a segment on Fox News
where they did their normal dog and pony show
where they talk about violence in video games
as possibly a cause for this shooting.
We've also seen the promulgation of the exact
same ideology that the shooter cites in his
manifesto.
People like Tucker Carlson and others say
this was just a lone incident of mental illness.
That's all it was.
There is no politics here.
There's no ideology.
There's no conservatism or liberalism.
And we also saw Ben SHAPIRO say, if there
is politics here, it really sounds more like
wokeness than anything else, which is, of
course, completely untrue.
The ideas in the manifesto are being espoused
exclusively by right wing political commentators.
Well, let me now show you some other attempts
to shift and place blame in absurd and pathetic
ways happening on Fox News.
Jesse WATTERS pulls out.
It's sort of like it's kind of like pulling
random reasons out of a hat, a MAGA hat, I
guess we could say.
Lockdowns, forced masking and woke ideology
are what Jesse WATTERS says really we should
be looking at as the causes of the buffalo
shooting.
Take a look at this.
This is from yesterday.
We have a.
Speaker 3: Crisis right now.
The American public education system is hurting
our kids.
Math and reading rates are plummeting.
Studies are showing that kids are talking
less.
They're already warning about a third of elementary
school students need, quote, intensive support.
But our leaders don't care.
They're more concerned about how they're going
to force masks back on kids.
Some school districts in California and New
Jersey have just implemented fresh mask mandates
in classrooms this week.
We're saying these kids up for failure for
a generation deep in a mental health crisis
after lockdowns forced masking woke ideology.
Kids are feeling depressed.
Just look at what happened in the Buffalo
situation.
What a teenager whose school system failed
him decided his only option was to turn to
the dark web where he was radicalized, a failed
education system.
Let that happen.
But the so-called experts think they haven't
done anything wrong.
Watch.
Speaker 1: So has Jesse Waters seen the Tucker
Carlson show?
Because if so, he'd know exactly what inspired
the shooter.
The shooter's manifesto, verbatim, has talking
points from Tucker Carlson's show in it masking
what what?
And Jesse WATTERS brings up fair and concerning
things.
It is true that COVID era babies, many of
them now toddlers, seem to have something
going on in terms of language development.
I read that that's concerning.
We've got to deal with that.
But the shooter's 18.
Okay.
The shooter was 16 when COVID started.
And the idea that that's what left the shooter
no choice but to go out and target black people,
even if it were the case that you had little
limited language development due to masking
doesn't make you go and target black people.
It's a completely absurd claim and they don't
know what to do.
They don't know what to say because their
ideology is verbatim in the manifesto now,
by the way.
Constant mass shootings also aren't happening
in any other advanced country where they had
masking.
And by sort of like North, you know, what
we call normal schooling, where you learn
empiricism and science and stuff like that.
They call it woke schooling.
They have it in other countries as well, and
they don't have the mass shooting problem.
One thing they don't have is ready access
to so many guns.
The party of personal responsibility, as you
can see, blaming the left for making this
guy murder innocent people.
This guy is a complete and total joke.
Now, here's another example.
This one's also from Fox News.
This is Kennedy, Lisa Kennedy.
She links abortion and the sort of disregard
for human life that she says is implicit in
abortion to shootings.
She says When we disregard human life, of
course you get shootings, wild stuff, just
not.
Speaker 4: And I know a lot of people, a lot
of Democrats who say I am pro-choice, but
I don't believe that we should be killing
babies after 15 weeks.
I certainly don't think that we should be
performing these procedures and celebrating
them at.
20 weeks, you have a lot of Democrats saying,
you know, we used to hear safe, legal and
rare.
You don't hear that anymore.
You hear people chanting about how great abortion
is regardless of how you feel about whether
or not the courts or Congress should be involved.
That is not something to be celebrated.
And we have lost the plot as a society.
So don't be surprised when there are mass
casualty events at the hands of sociopaths.
We have so little regard for human life and
that starts with basic decent conversations
where we have mutual dignity and curiosity.
We have to find a way to get back to that
place, even when we disagree vehemently.
Speaker 3: So you think that people who seek
abortions are sociopath?
Speaker 4: No, I'm saying that mass shooters
are sociopaths.
Mass shooters and people like that are raised
to have very little respect for human life.
And I think we have to get back to a place
in society where we do have respect for each
other, where you don't have people going on
the subway and shooting people and trying
to.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So it's a very, very dumb show.
But her argument is.
Mass shooters don't have respect for life
and for society.
And people who gleefully get abortions, as
she claims people do, don't have respect for
life in society.
And so the link is, in general, when you don't
have respect for life and society, you either
go and get abortions or you go and do a mass
shooting.
It's hard to imagine a dumber take.
It truly is.
But they are desperate to blame anything they
can other than looking inward.
And I get it.
It's hard to look inward when when the blame
is on you.
And again, we're not saying legal blame, but
when what we are saying is the ideology espoused
by the Shooters Manifesto is an ideology that
has been nurtured and incubated in right wing
media.
And Fox News is part of it.
Whether Kennedy herself talked about white
replacement theory or not, I don't know.
Maybe she didn't.
But at this point, there's no way that she
could not realize that many of the people
on her network are the ones pushing the same
stuff that was in the manifesto.
You look everywhere else abortions, the reason
or masking or woke education or whatever the
case may be.
They're not going to look inward.
But we have to remember that we know exactly
why the shooter did what they did.